is it good fella's where they had the
real kind of gangsters on set
well there were people around who you
know the same with casino and stuff
that's that's part of it does that help
or does it make you a bit nervous
no no everybody you know people like to
be in movies and part of them and the
guys in that world as much if not more
than most people yeah you talk about
that world what is it about movies in
that work cuz almost since they started
making movies they've been telling
stories about gangsters and mafia
mobsters and now here we are in 2019 and
this is still a big deal what is the
appeal of those characters I don't know
I guess it's because they defy the law
in some way and they still may have
their own laws their own there's there's
more of an honor like especially the
Godfather I think especially at that
time in the late 60s the Godfather with
the government and everything of yet now
more I think that the the idea that this
culture had more there was more respect
and more more structure and more right
and wrong then we were seeing in in the
war and with our leaders and not being
told the truth about what was really
going on and I think so that that's why
it was a part of its appeal yeah today
we have a kind of a weird twisted
president who thinks he's a gangster
who's not not even a good gangster
because this is a guy that you know even
gangsters like honor among thieves you
shake a hand you have your word that's
all you have yeah
there's your word and they have your
word and that's it this guy is not the
catch I didn't even bring him up ladies
[Applause]
[Music]
you